-Welcome back. We're hanging out
with Anthony Mackie.
Now, Anthony,
since you play an android
in your new movie
"Outside the Wire,"
I thought I'd put
your robot skills to the test
and play a game called
"Hey Robot."
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-Alright, so, this is based on
the real board game "Hey Robot"
that you can play at home.
It's like the classic game
Password,
but your partner
is a smart speaker.
Alright? So, first I'll pick
a card with a word on it.
Then we'll take turns
asking a question
to get the speaker to say that
word somewhere in its answer.
If it does, we get a point.
Ready?
-Okay.
-Alright.
I will go first.
Alright, the word is --
the word is "kiwi."
-Hmm.
-The word is "kiwi."
Okay.
Alexa, what are the top five
fruits in the -- in Australia?
[ Both laugh ]
-According
to an Alexa Answers contributor,
not necessarily in order --
banana, apple, orange,
pear, strawberry, grape,
peach, lemon, lime...
-Alright, shut up.
-...and grapefruit.
-She's still going.
-She said every --
-...on Alexa Answers...
-Alexa, stop.
-She literally named
every single fruit.
[ Both laugh ]
-God, you got to be kidding me,
man.
She named every fruit
besides kiwi.
You got to be joking me, man.
They don't eat kiwi
in Australia?
-[ Laughs ] No!
-Come on!
It's good for you.
They're healthy people
in Australia.
Alright, buddy,
it's your chance to steal.
You have to say the name
and then your -- your question.
-Already got it.
Alexa, what's a fruit's name
that's used as a nickname
for a person from New Zealand?
-Here's something
I found on the Web.
According to AsiaOne.com,
most people assume
the kiwi fruit comes
from New Zealand
because of its name...
-Booyakasha!
-Oh, my gosh, how do you --
-...it is also a nickname
for its citizens.
-Wow. Alright, okay, okay.
Alexa, stop.
Alright, New Zealand, yeah.
That's right. That's right, man.
-[ Laughs ]
-Gosh darn it!
Alright, one point.
-It's New Zealand --
it's not Australia, man.
-I know. I know. I know.
But they can eat --
-Fifth grade.
-You're not allowed to eat kiwi
in Australia all of a sudden?
Come on.
Live it up a little bit, man.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, here we go.
-They are tasty.
-Anthony,
you're up for the next round.
Here we go.
The word is "rectangle."
-Okay.
Alexa, what do you call a square
where two of the four sides
are longer than the other two?
-Hmm.
I don't know that one.
-Yeah, that's right.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Come on, Alexa.
-Bang!
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah!
[ Both laugh ]
Whoo!
This game's awesome.
Party, man.
Alright. Alright.
Rectangle.
What do I -- How do I do --
What is a rectangle?
-[ Laughing ]
"What is a rec--"
-Ready?
Alexa, name five shapes.
-I know about
a number of shapes,
including a regular pentagon,
a triangle, a trapezoid,
a circle,
and a regular hexagon.
[ Both laugh ]
-What the hey?! You don't know
what a rectangle is?
You say hexagon and
an abnormal pentagon?
What the heck?!
-[ Laughs ]
-Are you out of -- What?
-I thought you had it.
I thought you had it.
-Alright.
-Okay.
-You want to try it?
-Alexa, what's a shape
that's similar to a square?
-Here's something
I found on the Web --
according to Reference.com,
a rhombus is similar to a square
in two ways.
Both have
two pairs of parallel sides,
and both have four equal sides.
-Yeah.
Thank you, Alexa. Finally --
-No, no, no.
-Yeah, you just learned
something.
-If it has four,
that's a square.
-The word wasn't "rhombus,"
dude -- it's rectangle.
Sorry.
-[ Laughs ]
-I know maybe you didn't hear it
over the Zoom.
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, Alexa, what is the shape
of a football field?
-The geometric shape
of football pitch,
also called football field,
is rectangle.
[ Bell dings ]
-Oh, yeah!
-Ohh!
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-[ British accent ]
Football pitch -- there you go.
[ Normal voice ] That was, like,
even -- that's from England.
They have football pitch.
-No one says "football pitch."
-No. Alexa's from --
She's from Europe.
Oh, sorry. Sorry. Alexa, stop.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, here we go.
Tie game. Tie game.
Alright, here we go.
My turn again.
The word is..."zombie."
-Okay.
-Alright.
Um. Uh.
Alexa, what is the plot of
"Walking Dead"?
-"The Walking Dead"
is a drama show starring
Andrew Lincoln, Norman Reedus,
and Melissa McBride.
Sheriff Deputy Rick Grimes
wakes up from a coma
to learn the world is in ruins
and must lead a group
of survivors to stay alive.
So far,
nine seasons have completed.
Season 10 is currently airing.
-Alexa, stop.
I don't need to know the details
of the reruns. Geez.
-"The Walking Dead"
is a drama show starring...
-No, no, no.
Don't start it again.
-...Andrew Lincoln, Norman --
-Alexa, stop.
-[ Laughs ]
-Just chill.
-"The Walking Dead"
is a drama show sta--
-Alexa, stop!
-[ Laughs ]
-Gosh.
-Alexa --
she gonna stop talking,
but when you turn around,
she gonna talk again.
[ Both laugh ]
-Alright.
You think you got this one, bud?
-I think so.
Alexa, what do you call
a dead person that eats brains?
-Hmm.
I don't know that one.
-Oh. Alexa, name the top five
songs by The Cranberries.
-Cranberries.
-To just play songs
by The Cranberries,
you'll need to sign up
for Amazon Music Unlimited.
-Yeah, I will.
I'll work on that.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's from a for 30 days...
-Cool.
-...and then
you'll be automatically charged
$3.99 a month.
-Yeah, I know. I know.
Well, I can't afford that.
I already bought you --
-Cancel any time.
-Good. I will -- canceling now.
-Terms in the Alexa app.
-[ Laughing ] Cancel now.
-Should I sign you up and play
music by The Cranberries?
-No. I bought you.
I have spent all my money
on you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, you got this one?
-Okay.
Alexa...
...what is a character in
"The Walking Dead"
and their name begins
with a "Z"?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Laughs ] It shorted out.
There's smoke --
-I think she went to sleep.
-There's smoke -- There's smoke
coming out of it, dude.
That -- She'll never get that.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alexa, what's the name
of a "Walking Dead" character
that starts with a "C"?
[ Laughs ]
-A "Z"!
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
-The origin of C is closely tied
to the development
of the Unix operating system.
-No!
You said the question wrong,
man.
-Alexa -- Alexa -- Alexa, stop.
Alexa, who are the directors
of the "Halloween" movies?
-I know
about 34 "Halloween" movies,
including "Halloween,"
which was directed
by John Carpenter...
-Sure.
-..."Halloween," which was
directed by David Gordon Green,
"Halloween," which was directed
by Rob Zombie.
-Whaaa!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Clapping ] Yeah!
Alexa, stop!
Thank you, Rob Zombie.
That's what I'm talking about.
Anthony, I love you, buddy.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-[ Laughs ]
-You are the greatest.
Everyone, check out
"Outside the Wire,"
premiering on Netflix tomorrow.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
-I did not lose.
You asked my question wrong.